في هذا الحي قرب العاصمه الاوكرانيه لم
يسلم شيء من القصف وبالون من الصواريخ
الروسيه والطائرات المسيره ايرانيه الصنع
انهلت على البلاد من الجو والبحر على
السواء
حدث الانفجار بسرعه كبيره وكان مباشره
ومفاجئا وعقبته موجه غباره من بين جميع
الهجمات الصاروخيه السابقه كانت هذه هي
المره الاولى التي يسقط فيها الصاروخ بهذه
السرعه
معدوي صافيرات الانذار لجا سكان كياب الى
محطه المترو للاحتماء من القصب
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه تقول انها اصابه
العديد من الصواريخ الروسيه قبيل سقوطها
ولا سيما بالقرب من العاصمه
الى الشرق القتال مستمر في بخموت التي
يحاول الروس السيطره عليها منذ اشهر وتقول
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان المعارك
تحتدم فيها تصعيد الروسي يعقوب اعلان
واشنطن وبرلين التزامهما بتزويد القوات
الاوكرانيه بدبابات القتاليه حديثه وهو ما
ترى فيه موسكو انقراطا غربيا مباشره
العسكري وقد اصبح منخرطيني فيه بشكل مباشر
معهد دراسه الحرب ومقره واشنطن يقولون
روسيا تكثف هجماتها على الخطوط الاماميه
لتفريق القوات الاوكرانيه وهو ما قد يمهد
طريقه موسكو امام عمليه هجوميه واسعه